This isn't quite 99% of his book, but I am Roman Mars. A couple of months ago, as you probably know, we released our first book, The 99% Invisible City. It became a New York Times bestseller, and it makes a great gift. I am contractually obligated to say that. But one of the things that happens when you go out promoting a book is that you get interviewed a lot, and one of those people that interviewed me is probably my favorite interviewer, Jesse Thorn of the NPR show Bullseye, and he's also the head of the Maximum Fun podcast network. This interview was really fun and it actually got surprisingly personal,
这还算不上他那本书的99%，不过我是罗曼·马斯。几个月前，正如你们大概知道的那样，我们出版了第一本书《99%隐形城市》。它成了纽约时报畅销书，而且是个绝佳的礼物。我有合同在身，不得不这么说。但当你出去宣传一本书时，会发生的一件事就是你会接受很多采访，而采访我的人中，有一位可能是我最喜欢的采访者，也就是NPR节目《靶心》（Bullseye）的杰西·索恩（Jesse Thorn），他同时也是Maximum Fun播客网络的负责人。这次采访非常有趣，而且出奇地具有个人色彩，
and I thought it would be interesting for fans of 9% of his bowl. So here it is. This is me on Bullseye with Tessie Thorn. It's Bullseye, I'm Jesse Thorn. My first guest this week is Roman Mars. Roman hosts the podcast 99% Invisible. It's a show about the little-known stories behind everyday design and architecture. Things like prefab homes, trash can design, those little ramps you see on sidewalk corners.
我想他的粉丝们会觉得很有趣。所以，它来了。这是我在《靶心》节目中与杰西·索恩的对话。这里是《靶心》，我是杰西·索恩。本周我的第一位嘉宾是罗曼·马斯。罗曼是播客《99%隐形》的主持人。这是一个关于日常设计和建筑背后鲜为人知的故事的节目。比如装配式住宅、垃圾桶设计、人行道拐角处那些小坡道。
How and why did stuff like this come to be? Now, after the show's been around for just over 10 years, Roman is exploring those same themes in a book. The 99% Invisible City is a beautifully illustrated look at how cities work and why they work the way they do. Roman is also the founder of the podcast network radio Topia. He's worked in podcasts and radio for decades. I've known him for nearly as long.
这些东西是怎么来的，为什么要这样设计？现在，在该节目问世十多年后，罗曼正在一本书中探索这些相同的主题。《99%隐形城市》以精美的插图展现了城市是如何运作的，以及它们为什么要以这种方式运作。罗曼也是播客网络RadioTopia的创始人。他在播客和广播领域工作了几十年。我和他相识的时间也几乎同样长。
He actually came up with the name for this show Bullseye. He sent it to me in an email, list of ideas. Unsolicited, by the way. Anyway, I'm really excited to talk with Roman about his new book, so let's get right into it. My conversation with the great Roman Mars. Roman Mars, welcome to Bullseye. It's nice to talk to you. Oh, it's so good to be here. Thank you so much. So, congratulations, Roman, on finally utilizing a visual medium for your design and architecture podcast. Well, you know, it was a long time coming, big leap, but we finally did it. Yes.
实际上，这个节目名字“靶心”就是他想出来的。他把它发在一封电子邮件的创意列表中。顺便说一句，这是他主动发给我的。不管怎样，我很高兴能和罗曼聊聊他的新书，让我们直接切入正题。我和伟大的罗曼·马斯的对话。罗曼·马斯，欢迎来到《靶心》。很高兴和你交谈。哦，很高兴来到这里。非常感谢。那么，罗曼，祝贺你终于为你的设计和建筑播客利用了一种视觉媒介。嗯，你知道，这酝酿了很久，是一大跨越，但我们终于做到了。是的。
When you started 99% invisible as a radio show and podcast. Originally, it was kind of like made to order. It was in part driven by the desire of the AIA and architecture trade group to have an architecture show. Yeah. And I wonder whether you would have done a show on that subject, had someone not suggested that it might be cool. And what you were worried about trying to do audio about design. I mean, I think I already had the interest in architecture, but I don't know if I would
当你作为广播节目和播客开始制作《99%隐形》时。最初，它有点像是按需定制的。它在一定程度上是由美国建筑师学会（AIA）这个建筑行业组织希望有一个建筑节目的愿望推动的。是的。我想知道，如果没有人建议说这可能会很酷，你是否还会做一个关于这个主题的节目，以及你是否曾担心过尝试做关于设计的音频节目。我的意思是，我想我对建筑本身就感兴趣，但我不知道如果没有人要求的话，我是否会
have necessarily jumped on it as a subject had someone not requested it. But what I always knew was like, I like the idea of doing it on the radio because I knew that I and other people had real biases when it came to the image of buildings, the way buildings looked. And I was really interested in the problem solving and design aspect of buildings. And I thought that actually on the radio it actually made you understand the story of a building before you had the visual image and that could make you love or appreciate a building in a different way. I always thought that was our secret strength actually as a show. Well, let's talk about buildings for a second. The show covers much, much, much more than buildings. But what is an example of a building that is if someone
一定把它作为一个主题来做。但我一直清楚的是：我喜欢在广播中做这个的主意，因为我知道我和其他人在面对建筑物的形象、建筑外观时，都存在真正的偏见。我真的很对建筑的问题解决和设计方面感兴趣。而且我认为，实际上在广播中，它能让你在看到视觉形象之前就理解建筑的故事，这能让你以一种不同的方式去热爱或欣赏一座建筑。我一直认为这实际上是我们作为节目的秘密优势。好吧，我们来谈谈建筑。这个节目涉及的远不止建筑。但有没有这样一个建筑的例子，如果有人
looked at it, they might not appreciate it in the way that they might appreciate it if they knew its story? Well, you know, one of the first buildings I ever really appreciated in this way was when I was in Chicago, I was working at WBZ, and I took the architecture boat tour that the Chicago Architecture Foundation gives. So you go on this big boat and a dosen tells you stories about the buildings as you go along the river, and there's this one building in the Montgomery Ward complex. That's the headquarters building, and it's a really basic rectangular building, but it has these big concrete corners on it. And I passed it all the time. I never cared for this building. I thought
看着它，他们可能不会以了解其背后的故事时那种方式去欣赏它？嗯，你知道，我真正开始以这种方式欣赏的第一座建筑之一是，当我在芝加哥时，我在WBZ工作，我参加了芝加哥建筑基金会举办的建筑游船之旅。你坐上这艘大船，一路上会有讲解员沿着河流向你讲述建筑的故事，蒙哥马利·沃德综合体里有这样一座建筑。那是总部大楼，它是一座非常基础的长方形建筑，但它的拐角处有这些巨大的混凝土结构。我经常路过它。我从来不喜欢这座建筑。我觉得
it was boring, modernism really ugly. And then the dose until the story of the fact that the reason why it has these big concrete support columns on the corners was because the Montgomery Ward company at the time pride itself on this egalitarian hierarchy and they didn't want their vice presidents fighting over who got the corner office and so they made a building that eliminated any possibility of a corner office at all. And it just kind of made me love it. And you know before I thought of it as nothing ho--hum, kind of building. And then I noticed like, oh, there's real genius even in the architecture that I don't appreciate. It's interesting architecture and design are fields that like any other specialized field,
它很无聊，是真的很丑的现代主义。然后讲解员讲了一个故事：它之所以在拐角处有这些巨大的混凝土支撑柱，是因为蒙哥马利·沃德公司当时以这种平等的等级制度为傲，他们不希望他们的副总裁们为了争夺谁能拥有海景房或转角办公室而争吵，于是他们建造了一座完全消除了拥有转角办公室可能性的建筑。这让我有点爱上它了。你知道的，以前我觉得它平平无奇，是个很普通的建筑。然后我注意到，哦，即使在我所不欣赏的建筑中，也存在着真正的天才。有趣的是，建筑和设计同其他专业领域一样，
they're prone to specialization of knowledge and intense connoisseurship and professional knowledge. And stuff that Joe Blow off the street might not get. They're also at least theoretically, specifically created to be accessible, to be used. And that's kind of an interesting tangent to me. Like I think of all buildings on college campuses that the students all hate.
它们很容易产生专业知识的壁垒、高深的鉴赏力以及专业知识。而普通路人可能根本无法理解。同时，它们至少在理论上是专门为了便于接近和使用而创造的。这对我来说是一个有趣的切入点。比如我想起大学校园里所有学生都讨厌的那些建筑。
Mostly, but not exclusively made of giant blocks of concrete. It's true. I think that's what I love the most about it. And I think that the show takes into account the fact that this is the art and design that we live in. And it makes us feel a certain way. And we actually preference that when we present architecture, like we're not just the academic list of isms of modernism and brutalism. I like to pay attention to how these buildings make us feel.
大多由巨大的混凝土块组成，但并非全部。确实如此。我想这正是我最喜欢它的地方。而且我认为该节目考虑到了这样一个事实：这就是我们生活其中的艺术与设计。它让我们产生某种感觉。当我们呈现建筑时，我们实际上更看重这种感觉，我们不仅仅罗列现代主义和粗野主义的各种学术主义。我喜欢关注这些建筑如何让我们产生感受。
And that is part of the story. And it really is accessible because you feel it, regardless of whether or not you know anything about architecture, you feel this sort of sense of, like wonder, like there's a reason why when you go to Washington, DC, you kind of feel the federal government, like you feel this sort of glory and this stuff. And they were onto something when they
这也是故事的一部分。而且它确实很容易接近，因为你能感受到它，不管你是否对建筑一无所知，你都会感受到这种惊叹之情，就像为什么当你去华盛顿特区时，你会感受到联邦政府的存在，你会感受到这种荣耀感和这些东西。当他们这样做时，他们确实有所领悟，
did that, and you kind of feel the heaviness of realism. And then maybe I can tell you a little bit of the story of it to make you change your mind a little bit, to get beyond your initial, you know, visceral reaction to it. But that initial visceral reaction is totally valid and is part of the design and is worth talking about. I love the unintended and intended consequences of someone's intent when they design something and that weirdness that you might feel for some crappy concrete building that you have on campus. The mud library at O'Rillan is a brutalist masterpiece and everyone complained about it when I was there.
你会感受到现实主义的沉重感。然后也许我可以向你讲述一点它的故事，让你稍微改变一下看法，超越你最初的、你知道的直觉反应。但最初的直觉反应是完全有效的，是设计的一部分，也是值得讨论的。我喜欢某人在设计某物时的无心插柳和有意为之的结果，以及你对校园里那些烂糟糟的混凝土建筑可能会感到的那种怪异感。奥柏林的穆德图书馆（Mud Library）是一部粗野主义的杰作，我在那里的时候每个人都在抱怨它。
Like everyone thought it was oppressive and horrible and it kind of is. But it's also glorious too. And I just, I didn't know enough to appreciate how it was glorious. It's Bullseye. I'm Jesse Thorn. My guest is Roman Mars. He's the founder of the Radio Topia Podcast Network. He's also the host of the show 99% Invisible.
就像每个人都觉得它压抑、糟糕，某种程度上它确实如此。但它也很辉煌。而我当时了解得还不够，无法欣赏它是如何辉煌的。这里是《靶心》，我是杰西·索恩。我的嘉宾是罗曼·马斯。他是广播乌托邦播客网络的创始人。他也是《99%隐形》节目的主持人。
I've listened to the show since not to brag, but the first episode. I know you have. But I've listened to the show forever, and I remember very early on in the show's run having a conversation with you about it. And you telling me that one of your guiding principles for the show was no stories about people, just stories about stuff. And I have to say, you know, all these, all these, you know, a decade or so in, you have done a pretty good job of sticking to that.
我从——不是为了炫耀——但从第一期节目开始就一直在听这个节目。我知道你听过。但我永远都在听这个节目，我记得在节目开播之初，我曾就此与你交谈过。你告诉我，你对该节目的指导原则之一就是：没有关于人的故事，只有关于事物的故事。我不得不说，你知道，在经历了大约十年之后，你在这方面做得相当不错。
I mean, sometimes you have to tell the good job of sticking to that. I mean, sometimes you have to tell the stories of people to tell the stories of stuff, but it's never like meet the man behind the Golden Gate Bridge. It's, this person did this interesting thing that created the Golden Gate Bridge. Why did you leave aside the number one easiest technique
我的意思是，有时你不得不讲好坚持这一原则的功课。我的意思是，有时你为了讲事物的 ตัวตน 故事，不得不讲人的故事，但它绝不是那种“走近金门桥背后的男人”。而是：这个人做了这件有趣的事情，从而创造了金门桥。你为什么放弃了特写新闻的第一大最简单技巧？
for feature journalism, Why did you leave aside the number one easiest technique for feature journalism, which is this is the life story of the person behind the thing that you know. I mean, yeah, we do it occasionally and I do like humans to show up in the story and I do think that the story of the stuff is the story of humans and our values and the things we care about.
你为什么放弃了特写新闻的第一大最简单技巧，即这就是你所了解的事物背后的那个人的生平故事？我的意思是，是的，我们偶尔会这样做，我也喜欢让人物出现在故事中，而且我确实认为事物的ストーリー就是人类的故事、我们的价值观以及我们在乎的事物的组合。
But there's just something more fun about making a story about bigger ideas than a person and their feelings and not blowing everything down to some personal story. When you're watching like a biopic and there's that moment in the biopic, which is so on the nose as to why a person did a thing that you know they did later. And it's so just, this is painful. Like it's cliche, it's hard to watch. And I just wanted to always make it about the idea. And there's great characters in there. Like, you know, the curb cuts episode, you know, wouldn't have happened without Ed Roberts. And Ed Roberts is a real character. But it's about things that are not just him, but about all these things around him.
但把故事做成关于更宏大的想法，而不是某个人及其情感，不把所有事情都归结为某个个人的故事，这本身更有趣。当你观看传记片时，传记片里总会有这样一个时刻，它直白得令人发指，解释了一个人为什么要做一件你知道他后来会做的事。这太让人痛苦了。这就像是陈词滥调，让人难以卒读。我只想让它永远围绕着理念展开。那里有很棒的人物角色。比如，你知道的，坡道那一集，如果没有埃德·罗伯茨（Ed Roberts），就不会发生。而埃德·罗伯茨是一个真正有个性的人物。但它是关于不只是他个人，而是关于他周围所有这些事情的。
And I just think that's a more fun story to tell. Tell me a little bit. We haven't even given an example of 99% invisible story. So let's take that curb cuts episode. What was the design that that episode was about? It was really about those little tiny four inch ramps that make it so that a sidewalk doesn't come to a cliff when it reaches the street and makes it so that it's
我只是觉得这是一个更有趣的故事。跟我讲讲吧。我们甚至还没有举出一个《99%隐形》的故事例子。所以让我们以那个坡道那一集为例。那一集讲的是什么设计？它实际上是关于那些小小的四英寸坡道，它们使得人行道在延伸到街道时不会变成悬崖，从而使得它
accessible to people in wheelchairs, but also makes it more pleasant for all kinds of people. We don't want to, like, who have a hard time stepping up or for people who are pushing a stroller or any type of mobility that's different from a completely healthy young person. And it's about those and about the fact that they really do symbolize this movement that Ed Roberts was a huge part of. He was the first This movement that Ed Roberts was a huge part of, he was the first quadriplegic to be accepted to UC Berkeley. And the UC Berkeley, you know, grudgingly sort of made accommodations for him and he always pushed for it and pushed for other people.
对坐轮椅的人来说是无障碍的，同时也对各种各样的人更友好。我们不想，比如，那些迈步困难的人，或者推婴儿车的，或者任何不同于完全健康的年轻人的出行方式。它是关于这些的，也是关于这样一个事实：它们确实象征着埃德·罗伯茨在其中发挥了巨大作用的这场运动。他是第一个 这个运动中埃德·罗伯茨发挥了巨大作用，他是第一个被加州大学伯克利分校录用的四肢瘫痪者。加州大学伯克利分校，你知道的，勉强为他做出了一些便利设施的调整，而他一直在为此争取，也为其他人争取。
And these curb cuts became the symbol of making a more accessible world, which led to the ADA and all kinds of progression, and all kinds of progressive advancements in terms of people with different abilities. I don't think it ever would have occurred to me that sidewalks existed without curb cuts. And it feels like a big part of the show and a big part of the book is revealing the iceberg under the surface of the water behind things that you might not have considered, like curb cuts. You might have just walked up them your whole life and they had never occurred to you that
这些坡道成为了创造一个更无障碍的世界的象征，这引领了《美国残疾人法案》（ADA）以及各种进步，以及在不同能力人群方面取得的各种渐进式发展。我想我从来不会想到人行道在没有坡道的情况下存在。感觉节目的很大一部分和书的很大一部分，都是在揭示水面下的冰山，也就是你可能没有考虑过的事物背后的东西，比如坡道。你可能一辈子都在上面走，却从未想过
they made sidewalks without them as I probably wouldn't have to me. And there's this whole story underneath there. Yeah, I mean, that's what the name is 99% of visible. It's that the, the physical object is just 1% of the story in the history behind that thing. And what I love about it is in the 10 years we've done the show and, and with the book, and as it's been introduced to new people, is that there are these stories everywhere and they're really gratifying when you find them in the most mundane things.
人行道在没有它们的情况下建造过，就像我大概也不会想到。而这下面藏着整个故事。是的，我的意思是，这就是名字《99%隐形》的含义。这就是：实体物品只是该事物背后故事和历史的1%。而我最喜欢的是，在我们做节目的这10年里，以及通过这本书，随着它被介绍给新人们，你会发现这些故事无处不在，当你在最平凡的事物中发现它们时，它们真的非常令人欣慰。
Like you'd notice them for the first time, even though you've passed them all the time and you notice this richness there. And then you begin to have a little bit more fanciful, interesting day because you know, oh, there must be more stories about this other stuff and maybe I'll look that up or maybe there's something like about that in the book.
就像你第一次注意到它们一样，尽管你一直从它们旁边走过，而你注意到了那里的丰富性。然后你开始过上稍微有点异想天开、更有趣的一天，因为你知道，哦，关于其他这些东西肯定还有更多故事，也许我会去查查，或者书里可能也有关于这个的内容。
And that's the part I love about it. It's really fun to give people that sort of permission and a little bit of a prompt and the guide to help them find stories and delight right outside their door. You've always been a guy, in my experience, who really loves learning about something. And I think all the time of this origin story you told me about how you became a public radio person, which, you know, I mean, I guess 99% invisible
这正是我最喜欢的部分。赋予人们这种许可、一点点提示以及帮助他们在门外发现故事和乐趣的指南，真的是一件非常有趣的事。以我的经验，你一直是一个真正喜欢学习某事的人。我总是一直想起你告诉我关于你如何成为一名公共广播人的那个起源故事，你知道的，我的意思是，我猜《99%隐形》
is no longer technically a public radio program, but certainly remains deeply rooted in public radio and spirit for sure. And it was basically, you were getting a PhD in genetics studying corn. And you were listening to Talk of the Nation when the great racewarris was the host of that show. And you thought, well, I don't think I could do what racewarris does, but I could probably be the guy that looks it up and puts it on a piece of paper and hands it to him. That's exactly what I thought. I didn't know what that job was, but I was like,
在技术上不再是一个公共广播节目，但它当然在精神上仍然深深植根于公共广播。基本上就是，你当时正在攻读遗传学博士学位，研究玉米。当伟大的雷·苏里斯（Ray Suarez）是那个节目的主持人时，你在听《举国热议》（Talk of the Nation）。你心想，嗯，我想我做不到雷·苏里斯做的事，但我大概可以做那个查阅资料、把它写在一张纸上并递给他的人。我当时就是这么想的。我不知道那是什么工作，但我想，
somebody reads the books and helps him be so good on the air. And I would be really good at that job. That's what I felt like I could do. And so that's what I went to pursue. So what was the thing that made you feel like you could be good at that job, but that you didn't want to be a professional scientist that you were, you know, you were very close to getting your pH, I mean, you were 21 or some doogie house or age, but you were very close
有人在读书并帮助他在节目中表现得如此出色。我会很擅长那份工作。这就是我觉得自己能做的事。所以这就是我所追求的。那么，是什么让你觉得你可以胜任那项工作，而又不想成为你当时正在做的、你离拿到博士学位已经非常近的专业科学家——我的意思是，你当时21岁或者像道吉·豪泽（Doogie Howser）那样的年龄，但你当时非常接近
to getting your PhD at the time. So what led you to think I would be better at that than at being a scientist, a job that also involves looking stuff up a lot? Well, I think to be a scientist, and I didn't know this because I was very good at study in science, but I didn't really have the experience of being an actual scientist. And there's a real difference in the type of, I don't, it's like ego, but I don't mean that in any pejorative sense that you're driven by the thing you want to discover so much,
拿到博士学位。是什么让你觉得我做那个会比做科学家更好——这份工作其实也需要经常查阅资料？嗯，我认为要成为一名科学家，我以前并不知道这一点，因为我很擅长学习科学，但我并没有真正当过真正的科学家。而且在那种类型的、我不知道，就像是自负，但我并不是指任何贬义，那种被你想发现的事物强烈驱动的感觉，
like you want to be the person that does it, you want to devote all this time and I just was like, well, I just kind of want to know things and it's a whole lot easier just to read about things other people discover if you just want to know things. And because I kind of knew I was wired that way, and I was a very poor bench scientist, like in terms of like pipetting things into tubes, I was extremely lazy and bad at it. And all those sort of things together realized that I just really liked the pursuit of knowledge
就像你想成为那个做到这一点的人，你想投入所有这些时间，而我当时的反应是：嗯，我只是想了解事情，如果你只是想了解事情，去阅读别人发现的东西要容易得多。因为我有点知道自己是这种性格，而且我是一个非常糟糕的实验台科学家——比如在把东西移液到试管里方面，我极其懒惰而且很不擅长。所有这些事情加在一起，我意识到我只是真的很喜欢对知识的追求，
and I thought that graduate school was just going to be a continuation of being in college, which is what I really wanted to do. And so I just thought that this job of being a radio producer was kind of like being in college forever. And it turned out it kind of was. I write papers every week, I study things, you know, it's kind of just undergrad. I just never left Oberlin. I'm very grateful for the help that I have making this show. Kevin's on the line right now, so I wanted to, my producer,
我以为研究生院只是大学生活的延续，这正是我真正想做的。所以我只是觉得广播制作人的工作有点像永远在读大学。结果证明确实有点像。我每周写论文，研究事物，你知道的，这其实就是本科生。我只是从来没有离开过奥柏林。我很感激制作这个节目时得到的帮助。凯文（Kevin）现在在线，所以我想要，我的制作人，
so I wanted to make sure I set that out loud. But you and I share the experience of having, and it's an unusual experience of having made a public radio show by ourselves. I made this show by myself for many years and you made Invisible Ink by yourself and for a long time you made 99% Invisible by yourself as well. Although you had people contributing here in the early days. What did you learn from having to go on the air once a week by yourself without any one to check if what you were doing was good, and without anyone to see how they were reacting to it?
所以我想要确保我大声说出来了。但你和我有着共同的经历，而且这是一种不寻常的经历，那就是独自制作一个公共广播节目。我一个人制作这个节目很多年，而你一个人制作了《隐形墨水》（Invisible Ink），很长一段时间里你也一个人制作了《99%隐形》。尽管你在早期也有人在这里帮忙。当你不得不每周独自上节目，没有任何人检查你做的是否优秀，也没有任何人看到他们对它的反应时，你学到了什么？
That's one of the specific radio things. It's such a vacuum. Right. What did you learn from generating that much stuff that regularly? I mean, I think you learn a couple of things and they're kind of almost the opposite things, which is like you learn to have a certain amount of self-discipline and to listen to yourself and listen to your work to the point where you're so done with it that you're sure it's good enough. And then you also learn, if it isn't great or isn't perfect, it's okay. Any of that big a deal.
那是特有的广播事情之一。这是一个如此真空的领域。没错。从如此定期地产生那么多东西中，你学到了什么？我的意思是，我想你学到了几件事，它们几乎是相反的，那就是：你学会了保持一定程度的自律，学会倾听自己并倾听自己的作品，直到你对它感到如此厌烦，以至于你确信它足够好。然后你也学会了：如果它不是绝佳的或不完美的，也没关系。这没什么大不了的。
There's a new thing out, you had to put something out next week and it'll be fine. And I think that those two things help me as a podcaster because I think one of the issues with podcasting in general is people get into it and they love it and they love to be producing stuff and they love to be talking and connecting with people
有新东西出来了，你下周必须推出一些东西，一切都会好起来的。我认为这两件事对我作为播客制作者有所帮助，因为我认为一般播客的一个问题是，人们进入这个领域，他们喜欢它，他们喜欢制作内容，他们喜欢交谈并与人联系
and all kinds of other things. But they didn't have that time where they had to discipline themselves in terms of the radio clock and how to fit stuff into time and how to not waste your audience's time. And I think that the work kind of suffers because of that. And so I'm glad I had a period of time where I was like a meticulous self editor
以及各种其他事情。但他们没有那种必须在广播时钟方面约束自己的时期，不知道如何将内容塞进时间里，不知道如何不浪费听众的时间。我认为作品因此而受损。所以我很高兴我有一段时间像一个一丝不苟的自我编辑，
because it made me better today. But I'm pretty loose when it comes to that stuff. Like my team, 13 people work on the show now, including me, and they work in different capacities, but they'll pick out little things to pull out or to change or to have me retake something. And I'm just like, that's fine. I don't know why you're complaining. And I think that's just from doing it for 20 years and there's still in that stage where you have to do it perfectly, but they'll get to where I am eventually.
因为这让我今天变得更好。但对于那些事情，我相当随性。比如我的团队，现在有13个人在做这个节目，包括我在内，他们分工不同，但他们会挑出一些小毛病来删掉、修改，或者让我重新录音。而我的反应是：这挺好的。我不知道你在抱怨什么。我想这只是因为做了20年，而他们还处于必须做到完美的阶段，不过他们最终会达到我现在的水平。
I think that is such an essential and underrated lesson though, and it's like such a classic drama of the gifted child lesson to have to learn. I see it with my kids right now, and I certainly, it's something that I can relate to, which is, for much of my life, certainly my childhood and adolescence, my only solution to my perfectionism was just not to try and do anything.
不过我认为这是一个非常基本且被低估的教训，它就像是一个需要学习的天才儿童的经典戏剧性教训。我现在在我的孩子们身上看到了这一点，而且当然，这也是我能感同身受的一点，那就是：在我生命的大部分时间里，当然还有我的童年和青春期，我面对完美主义的唯一解决方案就是索性不去做任何尝试。
And I think that one of the reasons that, you know, stage performance and going on the radio once a week was appealing to me was that you have to do it. And when it's done, it's done. You can't worry about whether it was, you know, because you've got to work on the next one. Totally. I think it's, I think it's an important lesson. I think it's really good.
我认为，（你知道的）舞台表演和每周上一次广播对我具有吸引力的原因之一是：你必须去做。当它完成了，就完成了。你不能担心它是否，你知道的，因为你得去处理下一件事情。完全同意。我认为这是一条重要的教训。我认为这真的很好。
I remember I was, you know, I know, I know a lot of people in public radio because of how I came up and so I was once, you know, like visiting H.Y. Y. and Philadelphia and watching Terry Gross do her show live. And she kind of puts it together live, you know, there's some stuff that's pre-recorded. And I'm sitting in the back with their director, Roberta Shirok, as she's training a new director. And we're just like, chit-chatting and stuff. And I'm like, do you have to pay attention here?
我记得我当时，（你知道，因为我的经历，我认识公共广播里的很多人）所以我有一次（你知道的）去费城参观WHYY，看特里·格罗斯（Terry Gross）现场做她的节目。她有点像现场把节目拼凑起来，（你知道的，有些东西是预先录制的）。我坐在后面，和他们的导演罗伯塔·希罗克（Roberta Shirok）坐在一起，当时她正在培训一位新导演。我们就在那儿闲聊什么的。然后我问：你这里需要专心盯着吗？
And she's like, nah, he's got it. He's doing good job. Besides, it's not brain surgery. It's radio. It's messed up. It'll be fine. And I just remembered so much heart in that, because it's totally true.
她的反应是：不，他搞得定。他干得很好。再说，这又不是脑外科手术。这是广播。搞砸了也没事，会好起来的。我非常记得其中包含的很多温情，因为这完全是真的。
Like, I want it to be good. I have a contract with my audience to make something valuable to them to not waste their time. And then beyond that, the story of the show is something that is a 10-year story. It's never encapsulated until one episode. And so you just have to let some of that go, while still maintaining a quality that you're proud of, and I think we do that each week,
就像，我希望它是好的。我和我的听众有一个契约，要为他们创造有价值的东西，不要浪费他们的时间。除此之外，节目的故事是一个长达十年的故事。它从未被封装进单单一集里。所以你必须放下一部分，同时仍然保持让你引以为豪的质量，我认为我们每周都在这样做，
but it's good to let someone go. When you go to a new city in times when traveling to new cities is possible or advisable, what is the first place you go or the first thing you look for or the first thing you ask about? I mean, what I think is fun now is if I'm, if I'm feeling in the mood for it and it takes a specific mood is I kind of let people know if I'm going to go someplace. If I'm doing this the best way, people know I'm coming to Pittsburgh or coming to DC and then they'll like say, oh, I can let you into the top of this building or something like that. And that's sort of like that's the privilege of having like a show about design and architecture
但偶尔放手也是件好事。当你在旅行去新城市变得可能或明智的时期去一个新的城市时，你去的第一地方是什么，或者你找的第一件事是什么，或者你问的第一件事是什么？我的意思是，我现在觉得有趣的是，如果我，如果我有这种心情的话——这需要特定的心情——我会让人们知道我要去某个地方。如果我以最好的方式做这件事，人们就会知道我要去匹兹堡或华盛顿特区，然后他们就会说，哦，我可以让你进入这栋建筑的顶楼或诸如此类的地方。这就类似于拥有一档关于设计和建筑的节目的特权，
as people will like give you secret tours to things. You know, I like to walk a lot. And so I look for places where I can walk and experience the city that way. But each city is really, you know, really different. And so it's kind of hard to generalize. But I do a museum, I like a good, tiny museum, like a weird, specific, tiny museum. It's like, almost... I went to a museum called Modo in Mexico City last summer, which is the museum of everyday objects. I don't say, oh, my Spanish isn't strong, my memory is Opeito, they'll, Opeito. Something along those lines. And man, I was so great.
人们会带你进行秘密的参观。你知道的，我喜欢到处走走。所以我寻找我可以步行并以那种方式体验城市的地方。但每个城市确实，你知道的，真的很不同。所以很难概括。但我喜欢博物馆，我喜欢一个好的、小型的博物馆，一个奇怪的、特定的、小型的博物馆。它几乎是……去年夏天我在墨西哥城去了一个叫Modo的博物馆，那是日常用品博物馆。我不会说，哦，我的西班牙语不够好，我的记忆力是Opeito，他们会，Opeito。类似这样的话。天哪，太棒了。
Yeah, I loved it. I, you know, the Postal Museum in DC, you can go to all these other places. Shout out to Oni, the Postal Service Dog. Yeah, there's nothing like it. This is a taxidermy dog totally that wears a vest covered in postal metal. It's a nervous dog. Yep, there's nothing like it. This is a taxidermy dog that wears a vest covered in postal medals. That's just postal museum.
是的，我喜欢它。你知道的，华盛顿特区的邮政博物馆，你可以去所有这些其他地方。向邮政服务犬奥尼（Oni）致敬。是的，没有比这更奇特的了。这绝对是一只穿着一件贴满邮政奖章的马甲的剥制狗。这是一只神经质的狗。是的，没有比这更奇特的了。这是一只穿着一件贴满邮政奖章的马甲的剥制狗。这就是邮政博物馆。
Heavy with postal medals. You're like poor dog. They had to give him a new vest because he had too many medals on the first vest. He rode postal trains and postal inspectors and postal employees would give him medals at each post office he went to. Yeah, it's great. It's great story. Like I like a good, if there's a chance for taxidermy out of museum, like all that. Especially weird taxidermy. Well, I mean, I also think that there are places that reveal themselves more easily than others. Like, you know, you lived in Chicago,
上面挂满了邮政奖章。你会觉得，可怜的狗。他们不得不给他换一件新马甲，因为他第一件马甲上的奖章太多了。他乘坐邮政列车，邮政督察和邮政员工会在他去的每个邮局给他颁发奖章。是的，太棒了。这是个伟大的故事。就像我喜欢好的博物馆里如果有剥制动物标本的话，我都喜欢。尤其是奇怪的动物标本。好吧，我的意思是，我也认为有些地方比其他地方更容易向你敞开。就像，你知道的，你曾在芝加哥生活过，
I visited Chicago a number of times. I've taken that architectural tour that you described, but I think you would be hard pressed to walk around downtown Chicago and not appreciate it. It's totally. It is beautiful, like a spectacularly beautiful. Whereas I live here in Los Angeles, and you know, Los Angeles is every
我去过芝加哥好几次。我参加过你描述的那次建筑之旅，但我想如果你勉强在芝加哥市中心走走，不可能不欣赏它。完全同意。它是美丽的，就像一种壮丽的美丽。而我住在洛杉矶，你知道的，洛杉矶和芝加哥一样，处处都是伟大的城市，但你知道，说实话，洛杉矶有很多丑陋的地方，而且洛杉矶最好的很多东西，必须得有人告诉你，因为那是一个整体，而且去那里是个很大的麻烦。
bit the great city, Chicago is, but you know, there's a lot, I'm not gonna lie, there's a lot of ugly in LA and a lot of the best stuff in LA, somebody's got to tell you about because it's a whole and it's a whole hassle to get there. Yeah, and that's why like either either I talked to someone who was like a friend or or I let people know who who't know me, but know me through the show. And you need a guide for most cities. Like, you're totally right. Like Chicago lays itself out for you. Like, it is there to be appreciated, you know, like they, and they focus on that. But LA is a place where you are told about a place that takes 45 minutes to drive there and it's like a great hot dog stand
是的，这就是为什么要么我跟一个像朋友一样的人交流，要么我让那些不认识我、但通过节目认识我的人知道。大多数城市你都需要一个向导。就像，你完全是对的。芝加哥把它的美景展现在你面前。就像，它是为了被欣赏而存在的，你知道的，就像他们一样，他们专注于这一点。但洛杉矶是一个这样的地方：别人告诉你某个地方，开车需要45分钟才能到达，而那可能只是一家很棒的热狗店
or whatever. And food is a good way to sort of get you in a lot of different directions, which is another way I like to navigate a city as to food. And that's a great way to experience. So I do like those cities where somebody has to be your guide. They're just kind of harder, for sure, but they're worth it. What are some things when you are walking around in Oakland, California, where you live? And you see that your eyes might not have landed on and appreciated before you did this show.
或者别的什么。食物是让你从许多不同方向切入的好方法，这也是我喜欢通过食物来游览城市的另一种方式。这是一种绝佳的体验方式。所以我确实喜欢那些必须有人作为你的向导的城市。它们肯定有点难，但绝对值得。当你走在你居住的加利福尼亚州奥克兰市时，有哪些事情是你四处走走时看到的，而如果你没有做这个节目，你的目光可能不会落在那上面并去欣赏它们？
Oh yeah, well, this show really opened my eyes and lots of ways. So I love sidewalk stamps, often the construction company who laid the sidewalk if they did a building and then they tore up whatever sidewalk there was if there was a sidewalk and then they laid another one down and they often put an imprint of the company on the sidewalk. And those are all over the Bay Area. And you can even see the evolution of a company. There's one that got a schnor pavement. And then there's schnor and sons.
哦，是的，这个节目真的在很多方面开阔了我的眼界。所以我也喜欢人行道上的印记，通常是铺设人行道的人行道建筑公司，如果他们建了一栋楼，然后他们拆除了无论什么人行道（如果当时有的话），然后他们铺设了另一条，他们经常会在人行道上留下公司的印记。湾区到处都是这种印记。你甚至可以看到一家公司的演变。其中有一家叫Schnor Pavement。然后有了Schnor and Sons。
And then schnor brothers. And you can see the evolution of bringing the kid into the business. And then dad retires. And if you walk around Berkeley streets, you can see these stamps. And they have so much history in them that I think is really amazing.
然后是Schnor Brothers。你可以看到把孩子带入家族企业的演变过程。然后父亲退休。如果你在伯克利街头走走，你能看到这些印记。它们里面蕴含着如此多的历史，我觉得真的很了不起。
And I love the different easement markers you can see these stamps and they have so much history in them that I think is really amazing. And I love the different like easement markers that are like these little tiny embedded plaques that are like this space is not dedicated or something like that which are basically markers because the part of the sidewalk is often owned by the person owned's ability not by the city, but they're giving permission for the sidewalk to be there in order to sort of avoid adverse possession, meaning that the city just takes over because they've
我喜欢各种地役权标记，你能看到这些印记，它们里面蕴含着如此多的历史，我觉得真的很了不起。我喜欢各种不同的地役权标记，比如这些嵌入式的小牌子，上面写着类似“此空间未奉献”或类似的话，它们基本上是标记，因为人行道的一部分通常归拥有该物业的人所有，而不是城市所有，但他们允许人行道建在那里，以便避免因长期占用而产生的不利占有（adverse possession），这意味着城市不能仅仅因为他们占有了它
had it for so long. They have to put these markers around to say, well, no, I own this property. I'm going to let you use it for now, but I own it. And I love that that kind of weird, like legal, strangely bureaucratic information layer on the city. And I think that those things, because they're so mundane, and because they have this legally-is-language, I think they're easy to not appreciate or not really think about. But I think about all the stuff that came before it and the cool kind of story there, and I kind of like its awkward bureaucraticness, and I don't think I ever would have found beauty in that before the show.
太久而直接接管。他们必须在周围设置这些标记，以表明：不，这处财产归我所有。我暂时让你们使用它，但它属于我。我喜欢这种关于城市的奇怪的、法律上的、奇怪的官僚主义信息层。而且我认为这些东西，因为它们太平凡了，而且因为它们有这种法律术语，所以很容易不被欣赏或不被真正去思考。但我想到了它之前的所有东西以及其中很酷的故事，我有点喜欢它那种笨拙的官僚主义，而且我想在节目播出之前我永远不会在其中发现美感。
There's one of those sidewalk stamps outside my house that's relatively old for Los Angeles, living a relatively old neighborhood for LA, and it's dated 1923. And maybe 50, a hundred feet past that sidewalk stamp, the road ends. There is in fact not a sidewalk, it's just a narrow concrete road and turns into dirt. And whenever I see that 1923, I think that is almost a hundred years that they have not finished this route. Like 97 years ago, they were like, yeah, it was about three quarters done. We'll get there. And they just bailed. There's a story there. I don't know what it is, but there's definitely a story there.
在我家房子外面就有一个这样的人行道印记，对于洛杉矶来说它相对古老——对于洛杉矶来说这是一个相对古老的街区——上面标着1923年。在距离那个印记大约50英尺到100英尺的地方，道路就结束了。事实上并没有人行道，只是一条窄窄的每条混凝土路，然后变成了泥路。每当我看到那个“1923”，我就想，这条路他们将近一百年都没有修完。就像97年前，他们觉得，是的，差不多完成了四分之三。我们会搞定的。然后他们就放弃了。那里面有个故事。我不知道是什么，但那里面绝对有个故事。
We'll finish up with Roman Mars in just a bit. After the break, we'll talk about how the COVID-19 pandemic has affected the design of cities and which of those changes might become permanent. the design of cities and which of those changes might become permanent. Welcome back to Bullseye, I'm Jesse Thorn, my guest is Roman Mars. He's the host and creator of the Design Podcast 99% Invisible. He just released a new book based on that podcast. It's called the 99% Invisible City. It's available now. Let's get back into our conversation.
稍后我们将与罗曼·马斯结束对话。休息过后，我们将讨论COVID-19大流行是如何影响城市设计的，以及其中哪些变化可能会变成永久性的。城市的设计以及其中哪些变化可能会变成永久性的。欢迎回到《靶心》，我是杰西·索恩，我的嘉宾是罗曼·马斯。他是设计播客《99%隐形》的主持人和创作者。他刚刚基于该播客出版了一本新书。书名叫《99%隐形城市》。现已上市。让我们回到我们的对话中。
So one of the stories about design that's often investigated on 99% Invisible is the tension between the world as it is designed by designers and the world as it is used by users. You know, the classic example being a park with paths, concrete pavers or whatever, and then all the corners have diagonal dirt paths through the grass because people don't want to make 90 degree turns to get to take diagonal routes. And I feel like living in a pandemic, we are seeing design as it is practiced, flourishing around us, simply because it was something that was not planned for. Yeah. And something that we don't have enough understanding of necessarily to make perfect plans about. What do you see around you in terms of design that is a response to the pandemic? Well, I mean, that's what I love most about cities is I think that this city is this ongoing conversation
所以，在《99%隐形》中经常探讨的设计故事之一，是设计者设计的世界与使用者使用的世界之间的张力。你知道，经典的例子就是一个有小路的公园，铺着混凝土铺路砖或诸如此类，然后所有拐角处的草坪上都有对角线的泥土小路，因为人们不想为了走对角线路线而转90度直角。我觉得生活在疫情大流行中，我们看到设计的实践在我们周围蓬勃发展，仅仅因为它是一种没有被规划过的事情。是的。而且是我们不一定有足够理解去做出完美规划的事情。在你周围，你看到了哪些作为对疫情响应的设计？好吧，我的意思是，这正是我最喜欢城市的地方，我认为城市是自上而下的设计与自下而上的干预之间
between top-down design and bottom-up intervention. And that's where all the stories come from. And if I could boil down the show. That's kind of what the show is about in the end. And so Desire Pass is a perfect example of that. And what I noticed, you know, like in response to the pandemic was what I first noticed was how quickly everything happened,
一场正在进行的对话。所有的故事都来源于此。如果我能把节目浓缩的话。节目到最后讲的差不多就是这个。所以“欲望小路”就是一个完美的例子。我注意到的是，你知道的，作为对疫情的反应，我首先注意到的是一切发生得有多快，
like that the tape on the floor and the plexiglass and all that stuff, stuff went up so fast, and I was sort of bold over by the ingenuity of everyone, a fixing plexiglass to counters in ways, and having a two by four, and then I hook and then a string, and then plexiglass hanging, and then it being bolted to the, I just
比如地上的胶带、有机玻璃和所有这些东西，东西上架得如此之快，我对每个人的急智感到震惊——他们以各种方式将有机玻璃固定到柜台上，用一根二乘四木方，加上一个挂钩，再加一根绳子，然后有机玻璃就悬挂起来了，然后把它用螺栓固定在，我只是
was sort of amazed by how quickly all that stuff came up and you know some of it's super collusion and some of it's you know not very fun to navigate. But I mean one of the things that I noticed about the pandemic was so it's illustrating how ad hoc and haphazard the evolution of a city is and it's always been this way. It's just like we're seeing it in real time as we're dealing with the pandemic. And that is super fascinating, the parts that they can take on on their own.
对所有这些东西出现的速度感到有点惊讶，你知道的，其中一些超级搞笑，而另一些则，你知道的，浏览起来很不愉快。但我的意思是，我关于疫情注意到的一件事情是：它说明了城市的演变是多么临时和杂乱无章，而且一直都是这样。就像我们在应对疫情时实时看到的那样。这超级迷人，它们可以自行承担的部分。
And then there was a whole response during the summer with all the protests and like plywood coming up and then how people kind of respond to like, especially in Oakland, you know, like they're trying to like express solidarity., they're trying to express solidarity. And they're like, please don't smash this because I have this Oscar grant poster up, or something like that.
然后夏天的时候有一整套反应，伴随着所有的抗议活动，三合板被竖起来，然后人们如何做出反应，特别是在奥克兰，你知道的，他们试图表达声援。他们试图表达声援。他们会说，请不要砸碎这个，因为我贴了奥斯卡·格兰特（Oscar Grant）的海报，诸如此类的话。
And George Floyd mural. And there's that response where people are trying to express themselves and say that we're part of this too, and we're expressing our support. And that conversation is what makes a city interesting. And that's the stuff I like to look at. And what it will be interesting to see is what stays. You know, like I've noticed that the tape on the floor has turned into design decals where they have little footprints and they have a little statement on them that say, you know,
还有乔治·弗洛伊德（George Floyd）的壁画。有这样一种反应：人们试图表达自己，并说我们也是其中的一部分，我们在表达我们的支持。这种对话正是让城市变得有趣的原因。这就是我喜欢看的东西。有趣的是看看会留下什么。你知道的，我注意到地上的胶带已经变成了设计贴花，上面有小脚印，上面有一句小标语，写着，你知道的，
social distancing, six feet or something like that, whereas it used to just be blue, pain or state or something. And maybe that stuff will stick, maybe it won't, maybe the sidewalk cafes will look in the parklets and all that stuff that people are experimenting with will stay. It's hard to say. This is very personal to you because you lost your father to COVID very recently. Yeah, I did. And I saw that one of your first reactions to it publicly was upset over the system. Yeah. And not, you know, not necessarily the system in the, you know,
保持社交距离，六英尺或类似的话，而以前它只是一道蓝漆或类似的东西。也许这些东西会留下来，也许不会，也许人行道咖啡馆、小公园（parklets）和人们正在试验的所有这些东西会留下来。很难说。这对你来说非常个人化，因为你最近刚刚失去了因新冠去世的父亲。是的，我失去了。我看到你对此的公开第一反应之一是对体制的愤怒。是的。并不是，你知道的，并不是体制中必然的，
rage against the machine sense, but that if if someone had been at the wheel doing some designing and thinking systemically that maybe your father would still be alive. Yeah, I was, it was one of the big like almost overriding emotions like when it came to him and his sickness and death. One of the things I felt a ton of was just how unnecessary his illness was because it was a thing that the federal government just didn't take on and it became a political thing. You know, he died unnecessarily for dumb politics because somebody couldn't get out of
虽然无法阻止机械般的失控，但如果有专人掌舵进行系统化的设计和思考，也许你的父亲现在还活着。是的，这是我面对他生病和去世时，产生的一种几乎压倒性的大情绪。我最大的感受之一就是，他的生病是多么的不必要，因为联邦政府根本没有重视它，结果它变成了一件政治化。你知道的，他因为愚蠢的政治而毫无必要地死去，因为某些人自私得
their way enough to just like to care about the citizenry. And this is what governments are for. This is, and I'm a believer in government. So like I live on the opposite spectrum with so many things when it comes to Donald Trump, but one of them, with him and a lot of his Republican compatriots is that I believe in government. I believe that government is a representation of the things we do that we can't do alone and that we work together to create a better world together and we do that and we call that government and that's not something to be ashamed to have or to be dismissed or something
根本不去关心普通公民。这就是政府存在的意义。这就是……而且我是政府的信仰者。所以，在很多事情上，我的看法和特朗普完全相反，但关于他以及他的许多共和党同僚，我坚信政府。我相信政府代表了我们共同去做那些无法独自完成的事情，我们齐心协力创造一个更美好的世界，而这正是我们所做的，我们称之为政府，这并不是一件需要感到羞耻、需要被解雇，或者是一件
that needs to be made so small as to be non-existent. And this is the time when we need it. Because an individual's response, like there's nothing that my father could do, like he caught COVID in the hospital, like he was undergoing another procedure for, he had some vascular disease, like he was not a healthy man. And so that made him susceptible to COVID. But you know, he, he did the things that you're supposed to do. I'm least I hope in terms of keeping him safe from coronavirus, but he caught it anyway because there's a health system, you know, high hours overwhelmed with COVID cases. And that, there being a vulnerable COVID cases is something that that we could have stopped and it makes me mad that we didn't stop it
需要被缩减到形同虚设的东西。而现在正是我们需要它的时候。因为个人的反应，比如我父亲无能为力，他是在医院感染新冠的，当时他在做另一个手术，他有一些血管疾病，他并不是一个健康的人。这让他很容易感染新冠。但你知道，他做了应该做的事。至少我希望在保护自己免受新冠病毒感染方面他是这么做的，但他还是感染了，因为医疗系统，你知道，当时充斥着大量的新冠病例。而有这么多易感的新冠病例，是我们本可以阻止的，而我们没有阻止，这让我很生气。
It makes me sad that we didn't stop it. It's a tragedy that we didn't stop it and We're still not stopping it. We're still like having fights about the politics of masks and staying home When there's real things that stay here and they seem abstract to people, but they're not abstract You know, there's a core of stay here and they seem abstract to people, but they're not abstract. There's a core of a million people have died. And this requires system thinking.
我们没有阻止它，这让我很难过。没能阻止它是一场悲剧，而我们至今仍在继续。我们仍然在为口罩和居家隔离的政治问题争论不休，尽管这里有真正的问题，它们对人们来说可能很抽象，但它们一点也不抽象。你知道，核心是一百万人已经死亡。这需要系统性的思考。
It requires us thinking about the whole because the little parts of these sacrifices, the little parts of the things we have to do, you know, like I understand that they don't seem that important because you live your life a certain way and you're healthy in a certain way, but the totality of these choices, they have to be thought of as a design system. And, and if they're not, the response is, the result is, um, people like my father die. You know, I'm, I was really uncomfortable with the single day that I put that on Twitter
这需要我们从整体出发去思考，因为这些牺牲的微小部分，我们不得不做的事情的微小部分，你知道，我理解它们看起来似乎没那么重要，因为你按某种方式生活，并且以某种方式保持健康，但这些选择的总体结果，必须被视为一个设计系统。如果不这样做，其结果就是，像我父亲这样的人会死去。你知道，我把那段话发到推特上的那一天，我真的感到很不自在
and like 70,000 people, like shared it or liked it or something like that. I was really overwhelmed by being the center of people's emotions for that day. That's not a place I love to be. But I do think it's important for people to share those experiences. But I do think it's important for people to share those experiences. Yeah. Well, thank you for taking this time. And thanks for your great work. I've I've loved your show for so long. And I've been I love the book.
大概有7万人转发或点赞之类。那一整天成为人们情感的中心，让我感到非常不知所措。那不是我喜欢呆的地方。但我确实认为，人们分享这些经历是很重要的。但我确实认为，人们分享这些经历是很重要的。是的。好吧，谢谢你抽出时间。谢谢你做出这么棒的节目。我喜欢你的节目很久了。而且我也很喜欢这本书。
And I'm very grateful to consider you a friend. So thanks, Roman. Thank you so much. I'm so grateful. I mean, I should let people know that like you telling people to listen to the show 99% visible was one of the first ways we got an audience. So I'm grateful for you. Well, you helped invent this show.
我很感激能把你当成朋友。谢谢你，罗曼。非常感谢。我太感激了。我的意思是，我应该让大家知道，你让大家去听《99%隐形》这个节目，是我们最初获得听众的途径之一。所以我很感激你。嗯，你帮助发明了这个节目。
I had new people know that that I named Bullseye. Yeah, you named it. Roman Mars, it was great to talk to you about your great book and your great show. Thanks for coming on Bullseye? Yeah, you named it. Roman Mars, it was great to talk to you about your great book and your great show. Thanks for coming on Bullseye. Oh, it's my pleasure. Thanks for having me. Roman Mars, the 99% Invisible City is available to buy now. You can get it from your local bookshop or on the 99% Invisible website.
我让新人们知道我给《牛眼》命名的。是的，你命名的。罗曼·马尔斯，很高兴能和你谈论你那本伟大的书和你的精彩节目。谢谢你来到《牛眼》？是的，你命名的。罗曼·马尔斯，很高兴能和你谈论你那本伟大的书和你的精彩节目。谢谢你来到《牛眼》。哦，这是我的荣幸。谢谢你邀请我。罗曼·马尔斯的《99%隐形城市》现在可以买到了。你可以从当地的书店买到，或者在《99%隐形》的网站上购买。
That's the end of another episode of Bullseye. Bullseye is created from the homes of me and the staff of Maximum Fun in and around Greater Los Angeles, California, where, you know, they say, red tape prevents you from building homes here in Los Angeles, but they sure are building one right across from my living room. So you know, sorry if you've heard it. The show is produced by speaking into microphones. Our producer is Kevin Ferguson, Hesu San Grosio, and Jordan Cowling are our associate producers. We also get some help from Casey O'Brien and Kristen Bennett.
这是另一期《牛眼》节目的尾声。《牛眼》是由我和加利福尼亚州大洛杉矶地区及其周边的Maximum Fun员工在各自家中制作的，你知道的，他们说，繁文缛节阻碍了你在洛杉矶建造房屋，但他们肯定就在我客厅对面建了一栋。所以，你知道的，如果你听到了，请见谅。本节目是通过对着麦克风说话制作的。我们的制作人是凯文·弗格森，赫苏·桑格西奥和乔丹·考林是我们的副制作人。我们还得到了凯西·奥布赖恩和克里斯汀·贝内特的帮助。
Our interstitial music is by Dan Wally, also known as DJ W. Our theme song is by the Go team. Thanks very much to them and to their label Memphis Industries for letting us use it. If you want to hear the latest about what we are up to, you can keep up with the show on Twitter at Bullseye. On Facebook, at Facebook.com slash Bullseye with Jesse Thorn, and on YouTube, just search for Bullseye with Jesse Thorn. We post all of our interviews there. And I think that's about it. Just remember, all great radio hosts have a signature sign off. And I think that's about it. Just remember, all great radio hosts have a signature sign off. Bullseye with Jesse Thorn is a production of MaximumFun.org and is distributed by NPR.
我们的插曲音乐由丹·沃利创作，也被称为DJ W。我们的主题曲由Go团队创作。非常感谢他们以及他们的唱片公司孟菲斯工业允许我们使用它。如果你想听到我们最新动态，你可以在推特上关注该节目@Bullseye。在Facebook上，网址是Facebook.com斜杠Bullseye与杰西·索恩，在YouTube上，只需搜索Bullseye与杰西·索恩。我们在那里发布了所有的采访。我想就是这样。请记住，所有伟大的电台主持人都有一句标志性的结束语。我想就是这样。请记住，所有伟大的电台主持人都有一句标志性的结束语。《牛眼与杰西·索恩》是MaximumFun.org的制作，由NPR发行。
That was me talking with my friend, Jesse Thorn. You should really listen to Bullseye. His interview with David Letterman this year is like in my top five favorite podcast episodes of the year. We will be back with me hosting our annual mini stories next week. Take care. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
那是我和我的朋友杰西·索恩的对话。你真的应该听听《牛眼》。他今年对大卫·莱特曼的采访是我今年最喜欢的播客节目前五名之一。下周我们将带着我主持的年度迷你故事回归。保重。本期节目还没有评论。点击文稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。